everyone so just plain before I start
actually my CTO using the opportunity
put going slide but unfortunately
couldn't make it tonight so I'm
calculating p.m. so i'm jonathan i'm a
developer more or less and develop rock
on rock alright so just to be really
quick summary laura's we were startup I
mean bunch of different we have a budget
for open source projects so the
eponymous operating system and a lot of
distributed system components built on
top of that and we're very good uses of
go so probably the earlier companies to
kind of go all in all it's time to go so
you get a whole bunch of open source
projects and the place they're all
written in go with sort of pretty to
accessories so generally like oh that
preheat with that choice that experience
12 everyone is very fast develop the
portability is really what brassicas we
have with
operating system so it's really great to
it was played by nurses and as one piece
like that the Great's then library and
pleasure to develop generally but
sometimes they all go sometimes people
in completely one of the area we found
it a little bit a complete is in RPC so
as I simply were quite a lot of
distributed systems providers doesn't
have a quite about me to the RPC between
different systems component of the work
on and this talk is from a brief tour of
some railings what we're doing through a
porous some kind of stay the ecosystem
something more popular RBC systems in
sort of go to the bagging the success
the wii kappa suppose just some are very
quickly sort of like what is off easy
what about what we're trying to do well
your organ elbows i'm sure your
prettiness great service like updates
actuators i'm so very simple just to try
to cure my workers the plight of
computer work much and you know you want
to be able to buy access is the service
to different clients but finally
remaking I'm variable ideally everybody
go suppose plus support but rather uses
people are going to right kind of like
clients and right in the right Python or
Ruby or front anything it just sort of
you a very but now we think it's one of
the more
one areas focus on the business you know
any service running ultimately when you
can have a need to kind of visualize it
expected to be able to introspective
sort analyzes them from the front it's
really powerful to be able to provide
clients to be able to write lines that
run in the browser and then Phillips
wanted to focus on no Jess because he
found this great overall an official
logo of a he ain't rocket strapped to
each other dragging javis resource for
future ok so what a fitting service and
we've got a client up and run out in
JavaScript but how they interact so
first we think degree in physics one of
the first thing that you brianna is the
bows this kind of actions with the
client can make a service so in this
example since it security services we
have four existing the burglars and key
second thing to the client and service
need degree or types so you have this
barbecue and what we actually operate
what is the thing I thank you
look like super ticket analysis and then
we agree are still issues actually
communicating between your answers so
what goes our network and the network
was introduced by traditional operations
around things like legacy and area areas
and and then insisted this is
particularly on security service we
might want it to be rather than sort of
a traditional wagon quest responsible to
support strictly so we do screenwriters
so much i'm sort of our properties is
one from an RPC system first once
instances goes everywhere they go to
others we want to be really easy to go
so the first part support is like a
puzzle to be easy using native playing
government without necessarily having
fantasies lima is accessible and then
the next employer agrees on touch Tigers
is being able to support different kinds
of clients other languages and we think
is really really the best way to
approach is client generation and I'll
talk like that what you tell them to
come in and then as I mentioned we think
that web trainers very important so we
won't be able to talk to us about this
we're about to do our pcs trousers from
a browser so basically from JavaScript
and then finally yeah we want our
service to be high performing so we want
some because between as efficient as
possible in terms of
resource usage of memory bandwidth
latency I'll talk about all these areas
that will detail so first was ease of
use so I said that now ideally wanted to
be as native as possible to go so you
can think of this moment might be like
your ideal solution here where you're
using native grow types implement with
simple service which is simply
concatenated to two arguments together
so we have a very simple strike that
connects two strings and then we can
operate them operate on their natively
in our service and method on our server
object and that's all there is to it and
this is great because we can use all the
types of needed to go and we can you
drag the website immediately and
naturally but the downside there is that
the scheme is type very very directly to
the plantation and facilitate your file
for other other being able to sort of
change these came up without going to
constantly changing people's attention
so intently it might be to say because
chase off for the scheme and this is
sort of a so maybe a first pass of
analysis system just using raw JSON to
encode your pipes and then using HTTP as
the transport and this is ok but at the
end when your own you need to write the
marshals at our marshal copia type
go and eventually this gets pretty
repetitive and you can especially to
cognitive patterns defective internally
to try and make this less repetitive
okay the next property that we want to
talk about it sort of desirable for an
RPC system is class be able to generate
an interoperability with different
languages so one simple solution here
would be to just generate the type
bindings using something like quite a
box or Faison scheme or captain captain
part but then you know that doesn't get
used to a little I guess the scheme I
just really help you with the actual
transfer interval and then an
alternative solution would be just
exposed to the actual objects without
applying that schema and that's
something that you see with the native
RPC packages and go and then know that
works fine between those things but
doesn't really get far with any other
kind of client and it's a bit of a sort
of lack of discoverability return schema
you need to know all the names the
objects they can interact with in
advance to be able to use them so just
to touch again on ye client generation
is important everyone in this age of
life with webbing for the web api as I
one says they want to rest api and to be
able to interact with your service but
actually what they really want they just
want an api client pick a native client
library
language of their choice but you don't
want to don't want to write and maintain
that client might be formal so client
generations gets gets you that so client
generation what that looks like it's
coming up with a document that sort of
describes your API how can someone
standed local language and then you have
a tooling that can generate an APL over
in in whatever type of languages and
that generates the language specific
implementation of different types of
methods that your API supports and then
clients can use the API we're not going
to think about any other stuff that
curtain code or transport everyone gets
their negative native language specific
the rotation of the API so quick example
of what that looks like the other things
that visor is the communities API which
uses something called swagger talk again
the really nice thing about this is that
the API once you have this document
describing a DI to compare yourself
describing and you can generate all
these nice things like documentation
changes that people can explore to look
at all the types and methods and
everything API supports and then it's an
added bonus once you can interact with
maybe I directly to the browser you can
provide these cool tools to be able to
interactively exploit straight to the
browser so this is an example of just
exploring a google calendar api and
during a tour around so why is that is
important I'm sorry how can we actually
give them this is an ideal for us how
can we actually make this happiness so I
hear a bad word with the front end well
the different Department is the
difficulty of the front end is that it's
difficult to move
looking for the browser to sort of
commanding technologies so but it's very
stable what's out there so things like
JSON or XML HTTP s and web sockets are
very well well known very well supported
so wherever possibly what we want to we
want to use those technologies there are
there are some some some cool tricky
things like implementations of proto box
and so forth in JavaScript but they're
not really probably not worth the effort
there's a lot of compatibility issues
and performance problems so generally
Australian compatibly with front-end
pushes us to move awards HTTP or JSON or
into a p8 and then find the final
property that we want our business
system is efficient so we want a
serialization of types to require
disputed memory allocations as possible
when converting like to a farm along the
wire format we want sandwich to be
absolutely minimal so we don't want to
be having to when their expressive man
types i actually put on a wire we want
to use the mineral possible amount
absorb is expressly and we want to light
seek to be like you know latent
iterations to be dominated by the actual
property for the network itself rather
than or do serialization is irrotational
a quite magic so those are the full sort
of key properties that we're interested
in for oxy else and so I want to go over
a few
if you possibilities we consider that
chorus and some of the more popular ones
that go to your system so the first as
I've been talking about mostly is sort
of an HTTP JSON or anything but using
rather than just using those some of the
war types that I talked about for JSON
like encoding it directly to the ghost
drugs using a using a framework like you
discover your swagger doctoral level in
exactly second option would be using
HTTP and very box trucks to geography
see is a newer options comic quite
recently and finally I'll talk about
capital program alright so let's unwrap
these combination of technologies oops
HTTP JSON hopefully you've all heard of
these I was your tech career is probably
too simple pretty boring the list is
thinking here we're using HTV process of
the burbs and JSON forward to encode the
tight again I kind of really touched on
example that but then the interesting
part here is it's the client equation
and so to to kind of main options that
we've explored here the first one is
called discover your Google's discovery
service and this is something that
all developed and they use to the five
most of their client API so the basic
idea is that you write discovery
document which is just a JSON document
and then
there's sort of bindings for a bunch of
different libraries that can pull down
that document and dynamically generate a
full sort of client may go to that
language so we use this for more update
which is sort of our automatic update
service and we all cities within fleet
which is our distributed in it system so
both of those are described by discovery
documents and then anyone can download
that document and generate a native
client and language of choice which is
pretty nice and also very importantly in
terms of the front-end compatibility
there's angularjs bindings so you can
have these great web front-ends that
talk terribly to the api's with these
services but the discovery case that
doesn't mean very discovery science has
been very widely adopted outside of them
so it's not necessarily something we
stick with looking for something that's
actually catching on improper popular is
swagga which is having self-assess of
the world's most popular discovery
framework and as a this sort of a nice
framework you go from work in
communities for doing this wacko
generating circle okay so what are the
good in good about this first sort of a
pc HD JSON discoveries discover us way
well HTTP json everywhere so there's
lots lots of this tooling and debugging
tools and tracing tools so for that you
can use and just what there's Nick would
native support in newburgh go and
endoscopic book for generating binding
again first class support on the front
end clients
so for lots of generations for clients
for other languages but what's not so
great well some of the client
cogeneration for something that isn't
really as performant or as nice to work
with as others and then one thing that
we've a candidate and two pennies
particulars encounter quite a bit is
that JSON coding go it's okay but it's
actually pretty slow by default it uses
a lot of a reflection internal I'll talk
about some sort of options to thing to
mitigate that could lead off there
doesn't in for that very performance
vehicle applications chiasson encoding
that opens definitely noticeable and
also HTTP pretty solid vertical but it's
not necessarily optimized for some
things that we would want to optimize
our pcs or so for example the streaming
example early everyone scream q invents
few events to my community service HP
used one is not really well-suited to
that so actually I talk web it is using
a still using HTTP transport but instead
of using JSON using particle system as
the encoding and we actually use this
internally for what
distributed key value store so all the
IPC between sanity it was five exposes a
JSON API but all the internal our pcs
between the members of the costs are
implementing the ralphs protocol is
actually heard about messages going over
a GC and again that doesn't have it's
much more efficient than JSON parties
for coding and decoding as messengers
serialize don't think necessarily and
then the nice part about this is it
allows me to have since you just posting
and xpg so suppose you have ability in
theory so I have a flexibility to
migrate to 12 targets while still using
a shoe shoes the transporter beam is
so some of the frozen conservation area
for a buck again we can use all the
standard issue the debugging tools and I
took it to diagnosis and sort of things
of all things that's a transport layer
we again we have improvements in
efficiency or JSON for the serialization
where it starts to become a little or
what is one we're looking at money to
front ends it's possible without script
but there's a lot of dependencies
required and again as I mentioned
earlier it's not the most stable or
social point and I talking up that
common so a lot of Marshall exam is kind
of led to you and the goat the governor
buck support is normally first class so
we've had a few issues with the library
that we need to add ok gr pc is really
interesting operates during you came out
a few few months ago or announced a few
months ago very shiny and it's similar
to it should be a bird laughs except
it's using HTTP to your next generation
HTTP and also using a sort of next
generation of part about / 23 and so
since it's using
HTTP to you get a lot of the nineties
nice features along with it your
transport so for example co2 by
Australian communication between the
client server you can have multiple
streams over single TCP so that's one of
the great i mean that's that's all
pretty self-evident be great about
geography and very efficient very fast
also from day one that's being great
support across the road from manager so
Native Client generation in 10 languages
will say that some of that is actually
not feeling native a lot of those
implementations are wrapping at C
library but the goal one is negative go
which is very handsome and then he a
doctor's office this nice property of
being able to stream things quickly hd2
connection downsides are it's very young
I'm really not yet proven and kind of
Lee can be a big one for some people's
that this sort of a thing like to Leanne
around 82 it's bring your protocol into
binary protocol so it's not nearly as
easy to sort of get respect analyzers
HTTP 11 ish your father's there's no
current plan for browser support this is
something that there
they just not there the graz that alder
is not something I'd like a sport no
clear not normally a clear future data
another actually motivated is Captain
proto so first I'm going to talk about
in sort of native our pcs in that office
captain burgers is silver de protobuf
was developed by I think one of the
original print off developers and then X
google it has an interesting model with
sort of interfaces and object which is I
sell it to the go type system and it's
also similar to do the severe you are
familiar with that model it's very
efficient as a relation to serialization
and although the latest sports not quite
as why is the other options I talked
about it it's improving there is no
support and that's a really interesting
features like promised pipelining so
what that looks like is that rather than
you know traditional I can see we have
this sort of request response
request-response the client energy back
shot requests and send it to us over at
the same time so one of the big problems
with that was that this actually goes
for for ktc bottle cap hurting it just
for the serialization side of things
underway but doesn't come
today so to get around that all we could
do is fall back to using nation fee as a
transport become proto still using kappa
proto serialization format it's pretty
similar to http and protobuf itself
except it's a little faster so there's
really not a lot of other sort of
important difference to talk about the
only real reason that we chose a point
above to eat rather than kappa proto is
it we were ready using photographs for
the artist formats already quite
familiar with the tool chain around
building so how to users need sir you
know if we were aliens again today we
might decide you guys kappa pro because
it does offer pretty clear speed and
efficiency Oh brilliant so that's going
to talk about the different options but
I want to know what's or what the
numbers are like what the benchmarks
well random was working on a bunch of
benchmarks for the stuff that I sort of
played around with some of the stuff but
then somebody realizes it's kind of
silly this is not really good clear
comparison teams in the coffin it really
depends a lot of your appointments so we
can do some sort of high-level
theoretical mathematics and and what
that tends to show is that sir cosars is
a framework to what lassaria benchmark
developed by cloud fair what they found
was that her debacle cody and sort of
three to four times faster than json
captain photos maybe four to six times
faster than protobuf itself or some your
some metrics for encoding they're really
easy to test with your own data
reporting it's all your use case that's
what you're actually doing don't know
some of my chrome eyes before you
decided what you're really use cases and
what it looks like you so we have no
song for those of you interested we also
we have some other are concede
benchmarks that we do not have worked
out directly to compare this thing so
that's quick roundup of three or four
different opportunities but what do we
actually like really want your world
working sort of looking for we think the
geodesy is probably the future we think
it's got a lot of luck i'm part native
go to support like from the very
beginning building off the union's
experience
RPC systems at Google and using
channeling all that learning from
billion connections of further bufsize
problem HTTP and speedy and yes HTTP two
possible widely deployed we can see more
and more tooling around that and being
able to respect to debug games but and
so it's only going to get easy to use so
one sort of idea that we are here to
actually make this happen is to use this
school project called G opposite gateway
and what you have is a gateway does
proxies it serves as an HTTP JSON rest
sort of interface and it will proxy that
in a new gyasi request so for buick new
services clients the karate and you can
use the native GRDC stuff and mortgage
different my facebook supports and get
all the awesome features that it has do
particular provider to float latency or
efficient stream stream of screaming
endpoints the multiplexer personal
connection and store all the clients or
things that don't support grp see you
can use ish sleeves they should you want
json and generate a generator against
the geography stick and then provide
that from the
gateway service so what that looks like
here again all these jersey already has
support from other languages so I've not
really no all have first got support
already Sega talk directly to your grp
service and then you can run those two
obviously gave way to deal with front
lines so there are a few things this
doesn't this isn't quite a few today or
a few things that can be done DiNozzo
one of the issues is think we can't run
a Java server and a gay way of saying
port which makes it harder to do sort of
in place upgrades from existing it yes
there's some sort of open issues and
proposals to to deal with that it's not
possible yet to generate swags back from
a grp see definition but again there's
sort of some proposed proposed solutions
to that i'm not sure like a lot but he
never left all right so jealously is out
but gameplay we can't finish your ways
that our work needs to be done so one of
the sort of recommendations or things
that we suggest in the meantime the
first is that if you use json go there's
a couple of interesting offers to speed
it up FF json is it uses so it defines
it generates a bunch of types to get
around
reflect magic reflection magic that go
does only the default attorney Jay
something and you go geez go codec
public Protector's when civil we
recently someone problem if you've been
anything recently so attached to go to
be replacing a visa was going to json
with go codec and we saw you get two or
three factor three improvement in
marching to be the switch and I codec
which is very nice and if you're looking
to the future as we are then hopefully
you can get of all them start hacking
like you see in the Gateway can't make
it make it yeah or stapled contestas
improve or if you you know if you like I
don't really care about this job like a
fine thing why isn't talking about it
then great one you're pretty lucky and
you can just ignore that I leave you
something like a pro to prote above
which is more efficiently but this
doesn't have that support the freedom
alright and that's all I have and 21
what if interested weapon this stuff
with a hiring it for us so take out a
bit thanks